hey folks my name is jake and today we
are taking a look at a cyberpunk 2077
mod
that lets you respect your character now
in the base game you can actually
respect your perk points by purchasing a
very very expensive
item however there is no way to reset
your attributes this means that whatever
you pick you're just kind of stuck with
that
fortunately this mod lets you respect
your attribute points and reset your
perk points so you can experiment with
different kind of builds
you can also save different builds and
load them into new games to make a sort
of new game plus mode that's where this
mod respector comes into play so if you
have cyber engine tweaks installed you
can install respector and then when you
hit the tilde key on your keyboard
you should get greeted by this menu
right here it's not
the prettiest looking menu but it does
exactly what we want it to do and
it does it pretty simply to be honest so
as you can see right here you can either
reset your perks
or you can reset your attributes i just
did both for this video
i was playing as an intelligence build
but i kind of wanted to try out
a full reflex blade build because you
know that sounds pretty fun
so i reset all my attributes and then i
reset my perks
once i reset my perks i was able to go
into my perks menu
and basically i had every single perk i
had earned throughout the game
just unused which as you can see ended
up at 58 so i pretty much just invested
all the way into blades and then a
little bit into cool to give myself a
little bit of a stealthier side anyway
let's see how that plays out
so as you can see the blades are much
better when you actually do invest in
that surprise surprise but what's more
interesting about this mod
is that you can actually save the
different builds you create
and load them up on the fly so this lets
you try out a bunch of different builds
it also more importantly or more
interestingly
lets you transfer a build into a new
game
which is more or less new game plus now
i believe you still have to start a new
game
and you can pick a different life path
you can create a new v and then once
you're there you just load your old
character this also comes with all your
crafting components vehicles
etc but you can also turn that stuff off
so if you don't want the items in your
backpack or your equipped gear whatever
it might be you don't have to take that
with you you can just take
your specs as is now i did have a little
bit of an
issue i wasn't able to save this spec
i only tried once so hopefully you won't
run into that issue but this is an issue
that i ran
into one other thing worth mentioning is
that if you plan on messing around with
these mods which i'll include links
below so if you want to check them out
you can do that you should always save
your game before you start messing
around with this stuff
i didn't have any issues i messed around
with this mod for about an
hour but you never know right it could
break your save or something like that
so just be careful and keep that in mind
if you do try that but anyway let's mess
around a bit with another build
which is a fist build because that's
something i would normally
never invest in we're gonna make a spec
i invested
all into body and then i put all my
perks into street brawler
and let's see how this fairs
more
huh
and there you have it i got to roleplay
as the strongest
puncher or street brawler in night city
which
was actually kind of fun uh it's
something that i didn't really seem that
interested in
initially but it's actually kind of fun
and more importantly
using this mod would probably help a lot
if you want to do the street fighting
missions because those by themselves are
pretty tough especially if you don't
have gorilla arms like i have right now
hell this mod could just be used in a
way to slant your build a little bit to
make you a little bit more proficient in
fighting to help you get
through those quests because some of
them are actually pretty tough
if you want to trout this mod on your
own i left a link to the page down below
as well as a link to cyber engine tweaks
which you will need
installed in order to run this mod if
you're after more cyberpunk 2077
content make sure to subscribe and check
out our comprehensive spoiler chat that
just went live
see you next time
[Music]
you